Keren, thank you so much for joining
me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Great. Thank you for having me.
You know just a few months ago,
we met for coffee back in Israel.
Who would have imagined that
here we are in the middle of May,
trying to figure out how the world
is gonna look like next month?
Right. Right.
I couldn’t imagine.
Now, Keren, you have a
particularly interesting story.
And I'm very excited to talk
about one of the programs that
you founded called Woman2Woman,
a leadership excellence program
that helps women both from
the tech units. But also, from
all across the industry.
A really extraordinary women
all over Israel.
To take great strides toward
becoming better leaders.
And having prominent positions
in the industry. Can you tell me
a little bit about
where you come from?
And how this idea of
woman2woman actually came about?
Sure, so I'm a 8200 graduate.
And so, in the unit we have
50% female soldiers.
Which is something that
usually surprises people
who didn’t serve in the unit.
Because when you hear about successful
entrepreneurs or people who go out
to a leadership positions in Israel
you usually hear about men.
So, there are 50% female.
And what we found out,
one of the co-founders,
with me and two other founders.
And what we found out is that,
there are two factors
that actually, that they are putting
women in a different stage. Right?
So, first is that women
usually take a step back.
Even before they think about
their career and having a family.
So, even when they choose
what to study. Or where to go.
Or what to do in their life.
And that the second thing is that
we have others lack of women
that could be role models in Israel.
So, women that gets to
high level positions and are
willing to pass it forward. So, that's
how we founded woman2woman.
With the idea of creating the next
generation female leaders in Israel.
Women with all industries.
So, let's dive a little bit deeper.
So, talk to me a little bit about
what does it take to create
a leadership program?
And also, what skills do you think
are missing to help bridge that gap?
Skills that you're trying to promote
through woman2woman?
So, I think that women, and again
generally, I think there are at least
good as men.
Of course there are a lot better.
Keren, you know,
that's not even a question you know.
Thank you. So, I think that there are
things that, again generally,
women are not that good at.
And it goes to soft skills that
relate to negotiation or
presentation or even presenting
themselves in a way.
Like talking about all of the
successful things that they have done.
And their attributes. So, it’s difficult
for women to talk about that.
And we feel that this is something
that we need to work on with them.
So, that's one thing. And also,
understanding that they could do both.
Like, having a successful career
and a family. Which is something that
if you look at the last generation,
you know our parents.
So, usually women took different role
in the house, right? So, right now
we wanted to change that.
And it's actually the first time,
the first generation that we really
wanna have equal opportunities.
And that's something that is not
really happening even in 2020.
Yeah. You know, I mean right now
it's very evident. You have women
like Sheryl Sandberg, and Rona Segev,
and [--]
That are really you know, pioneers.
And they are doing
extraordinary things.
But you also have these crazy stories
of Marissa Meyer. You know
back then the CEO of Yahoo,
who gives birth and
I think the Meet was on the--
Three days.
Three days she was in the office.
I mean, wow. And I'm sure
you have to find some balance, right?
I can’t imagine that it can be
assumed that either the women
or the men will come to the office
three days after giving birth.
But what can you do to sort of
level the gap between the
maternity leave of the women
and that of the father?
That's a great point. So, first
I believe that every woman
has her own choice, right?
And if she thinks that she can
come back to the office after a day
or two days or three days, that's fine
Because she needs to feel good
with herself. And you know,
women experience this
maternity leave in different ways.
Which is okay. And I think that
part of asking for equality
and equal opportunities,
is also understanding that women
are also different among themselves.
According to what they believe
and what they've seen.
The way they feel about family.
And we really need to accept that.
We really need to give, each woman
her own choice to have
and navigate her life
and course this to major things
which are career and her own
professional life. So, that's first.
Second, I agree that we have
missing women that are pioneers.
And also, you know programs.
We have Orna Berry
and we have [--].
Really amazing women.
And they are really putting their time
in order to help younger women
which is amazing in my opinion.
And they also talk
about their difficulties.
Which there are a lot of them.
Also, in their balance, you know work,
and family, and what they have done
in order to balance that.
Completely. And you also see
other companies in the industry
who are taking the reverse approach
and they're saying,
"Why is it that women only
are expected to spend time
with the family? Men, the fathers
should be there just as much,
just as long as the women."
And I believe that both Google
and Facebook, they took their step
in equalizing the paid vacation leave
after giving birth.
So talk to me a little about
woman2woman.
How does the program actually run?
Because these women are already,
they are excellent candidate for
continuing in leadership positions.
They are very busy. Is it structured
like an EMBA sort of?
Or is that a meet-up base?
How does it work?
So the program is about six-month.
During this six-month we have
one on one mentoring
Like one on one mentorship.
So, we have these mentors.
Amazing mentors on one side
and the younger women
on the other side.
Right.
And they are meeting each other
through this six-month.
And besides that, we have a lot of
meet-ups for the mentors
and the mentees. So, with the
mentees we're working
as I said about their soft skills.
And even creating their path, right?
So, where they wanna go
when they wanna get this
kind of positions,
what they wanna achieve
family-wise, and how do they really
navigate their career.
And we're working with them on that.
And then on the mentor side,
we also work on creating a
very very very very influential
group of women in
high leadership positions.
That are working in order to promote
women inter-organizations.
Right. And this mentorship,
it's actually what's unique about it
is that you're forming this
really incredible relationships
with some of the most prominent
women in the Israeli ecosystem.
And it's not just a one of,
"Hey, give me an hour coffee
and let me share
some of my dilemmas."
You're actually building these
intense relationships where they go
as far to help their mentees progress
to the C-level and executive positions.
Is that right?
Right. Right.
What we understood is that
even in 2020, even though we have
very very talented women
around the age of 30 let's say,
when you look at this point.
So, even so that they are so talented,
and they wanna get to the
C-Levels positions, not all of them
are going to get there. And not
because they are not good enough.
It's just because of life, right?
Because they would have much more,
it would be much more difficult for them.
So, what we do is just we take them
hand by hand and we just
make sure that they are reaching
in those positions.
Okay. So how many cycles has
this program gone through?
And how many women have gone
through this program?
So, we've already had four cycles.
And more than 160 mentees.
Wonderful. 160 mentees.
That's a lot of data. Am a data guy.
I love looking at data.
And extrapolating to some of the
bigger picture of questions.
And what have you learned over these
160 mentees? All extraordinary women
to begin with. I'm sure some of them
went on to already become
C-Level executives. Some of them
are on their way. Some of them
perhaps have realized that
they don’t actually want to.
Or maybe they are not fit for that.
I'm sure that's a possibility too.
What earned secrets have you learn
as the founder of this,
looking at these 160 women?
So, I think that I've learned that
how important it is to have a community.
That supports you. So, some of them
are coming from different backgrounds.
And different ethnicities, right.
So, some of them are Haredi
and some of them are non.
And some of them different
communities in Israel.
You have parading them in the program?
Yeah. We do.
Really. Wow. Okay.
Which is amazing. Yup.
And you know, arm and hammer,
like different communities.
And not all of them are coming
from a background that really
supports them and pushes them.
So, I feel like having this community.
I'm talking about the mentees themselves.
Not the mentors.
So, having this community
of women that help each other,
and open doors for each other.
This is something amazing.
I've heard one of our [--].
So, she told me like, she called,
I gave her a number of one of our
alumni from the first cycle.
And I didn’t tell her that
I'm giving her number.
So, she called and the other person
on the line. So, she was like,
"Are you want to be an alumni?
Okay. I will help you. I will do
whatever you need. I will help you
in whatever I can."
So, they are really helping each other.
And I think that's a gift.
Oh. That one's incredible.
Yeah. I think about this question a lot
as the chicken and the egg sort of.
Where you expect on one hand.
I'm looking now on the cyberspace
in 8200 where even though the unit
as a whole has an equal ratio of
male to females. In the cyberspace,
I think it's more like 9:1 male to female.
Which is also, there are a lot of programs
trying to help make that transition
more to equality.
But what I were thinking about,
and I had a third of my team
where females. So, we're actually
broke the law that for the rest of them
and was very proud of.
And I kept thinking that,
like "Wow". I can imagine the struggle
of even when you get a fantastic
woman engineer or analyst
or whatever to come in.
She has to go. And I'll sit in a room,
with seven, eight other guys
with very few representation
of other women.
That's very intimidating and
I'm thinking back to high school.
Where you have CS classrooms
filled with men.
That's intimidating to go and
be the one out.
And I'm almost wondering
how do we break the cycle
where we stop this intimidation
and we just level the plain field.
Very good question.
So, I think of that, what we do is
we work with companies in Israel.
So, exactly as you said.
Being the only woman at the room
is very difficult. It's very hard.
So, were working with companies
in order to have them change
the way that they are thinking about.
Even according women.
We're talking to managers
that are men about the differences
and they are working and
how they are performing the interviews.
And then, like even the sitting.
And what happens when
a woman is pregnant? So, sometimes
she needs to have a parking space
sometimes. And sometimes,
there are different things
that a woman needs or that would
help her achieve her potential, right?
So, were really working with companies.
In order to help them create an
environment that enables women
to get to the high-level positions.
Wonderful.
Keren, we have just about
five minutes left. And I’d love
to use this time to learn a little bit
more about you. So, tell me
where do you come from?
You did 8200. You founded this
incredible organization that is now
continuing to do great things.
But you're also working full time
in the industry. So, tell me a little bit
about what interest you?
And what excites you?
So, I'm really excited about
changing things that I don’t really
agree with. So, it also relates to women.
And to deal with woman equality
and to other communities in Israel
that are currently not having the same
representation as they should have.
In the industry. So that's something
that really excites me. And I really,
so I'm working in the finance industry.
In the cybersecurity in Australia.
A finance position. I really love that.
I really like the combination
of thinking about the next product
and how you go to the market
and how to get money out of that.
So, I really like that. I think that's it.
So, tell me a little bit about
how do you balance these things?
So, you're running this organization
that takes a lot of time to work on.
It's a lot of relationship building.
A lot of meetings and effort.
I know from organizing
a hackathon event, which are
one-time events that facilitates
these relationships.
That takes a lot of effort.
At the same time, you're working
full time at a company.
And you're also probably working
on other stuff that you're excited about.
How do you balance everything?
So, I think that I found a way
that also, like when I'm coming
to project, I really understand
what it takes. Like how many hours
I'm going to spend on that.
I don’t have weekends.
I have a wonderful husband.
And amazing friends and family.
They are very supportive.
And that's something that really helps.
And I also think that once you do
something that you really love
and you care about. And so, your life,
everything is sort in a better way.
Everything is okay.
So, if I asked you how many hours
a week do you work? Because
you know, full time jobs takes 40 hours.
But you're actually saying that,
"I don’t work for 40 hours."
Technically, I work for much more
but I don't consider that as work.
Right. Right. Correct.
So, usually I do 30 hours of
volunteering a week.
And I work 50 hours or more of work.
How do you balance 30 hours?
Like I don’t sleep much.
Where do you volunteer?
What is your volunteer work?
So, woman2woman takes a lot of time.
We're now 12 women at the team.
Which is amazing.
But it still takes a lot of time.
Is everybody volunteer?
We have someone that is helping us
and get full time job.
But all the others are volunteering.
And yeah. I do a lot of stuff
that I really believe in.
That's wonderful. How do you
from the sidelines make sure that
the quality remains as when you
just started out? Because it's a very
emotional, personal project.
And I'm sure that you know sometimes
there are decisions being made that
you're not entirely happy with.
Or that you don’t feel are the best.
How do you balance now that you are
also working on other stuff?
Very good question. When I'll know
the answer Ill get back to you.
Wonderful
So, it's hard. I tried to do compromises
when I feel that I can do that.
And keep the quality in the
highest level in places where I feel
we can compromise on.
So, just balancing between our
activities and things that we are doing
in order to maintain the brand.
And the amazing women that are
coming to our program.
Okay. That's wonderful. Keren,
we are almost done. But I'd love to
ask you my favorite question.
The three words that best
describe yourself. Or three words that
one of 160 women who went through this
wonderful program would describe you as.
So, I think the three words
to describe the program and
what we're trying to do is like
Create, Change, and Impact.
I love it. Keren,
thank you very very much.
Toda raba. Stay safe.
And I look forward to our next coffee
back in Israel whenever that will be possible.
Looking forward.
Wonderful. Thank you.
Take care.